la misère et violence après trois ans
passés à la rencontre de personnes
vivant dans la pauvreté sur les cinq
continents c'est la conclusion du
mouvement international atd quart monde
alors du public au colloque
international qui s'est tenue à la
maison de l'unesco à paris en janvier
dernier ce sera donc le thème de la
journée mondiale du refus de la misère
du 17 octobre bonsoir dominique vienne
vous êtes le responsable date était
quart monde pourquoi cette conclusion la
misère et violence ce qu'il faut dire
tout d'abord c'est que ce travail était
fait en relation directe et en faisant
que les personnes les plus exclues à
porte même le rap lors leur contribution
à cette ses études donc on a eu un
certain nombre de séminaires qui ont été
faits dans diverses parties du monde et
comme vous le disiez on a conclu
l'ensemble de ce colloque à paris au
mois de janvier les conclusions c'est
que malheureusement on a un certain
nombre de violences qui sont subies par
les personnes les plus exclues que ce
soit celle qu'on connaît le plus
communément les privations matérielles
un privation de revenus pré version
d'habitation de cette la privation de
nourriture mais qui entraîne des
phénomènes de survie de la part de ces
personnes les plus exclues et qui font
qu'ils ne sont concernés malheureusement
que par le court terme et sont ils
peuvent pas ils n'ont pas les moyens
puisqu'il faut savoir le matin ce qu'on
va donner à manger aux enfants le soir
ils ne peuvent pas se projeter dans le
long terme ça c'est la première
problématique qui a été soulevée
privations également je dirais du savoir
privations parce que malheureusement
l'école même si elle est ouverte à tous
en france le succès n'est pas là pour
tout le monde donc on s'est beaucoup
battu sur le succès on a fait récemment
des propositions pour le succès de tout
le monde à l'école donc ça c'est le
deuxième type de privations qui en
tiennent de ce fait là un certain mépris
puisque quand on n'a pas le savoir on
est méprisé par les autres personnes par
les autres personnes de la société
mépris qui lui-même entraîne le certaine
humiliation certaine discrimination le
fait qu'on se comprennent pas et de ce
fait là qu'on n'apporte pas les bonnes
solutions à cette problématique de la de
la pauvreté et l'exclusion doxa crée
également 2 chez ces personnes qui sont
exclues et un doute on se demande ce
dont on est capable et au fini par se
terrer se taire ne se terre dans le sang
silence a
observé un certain silence et de se
terrer dans le sens donc on veut pas se
montrer ça c'est ce qui est plus
problématique
justement la misère et violent c'est
également dans ce rapport dans ses
conclusions il est mentionné les
violences institutionnelles et
politiques absolument oui parce que bon
c'est bien que malheureusement il ya un
certain nombre de
2,2 de maintien de personnes très
pauvres dans l'exclusion de l'un sur une
discrimination des expulsions on les vit
au jour le jour des décret anti
mendicité qui sont qui sont passés
l'habitat indigne et qui continue le
fait qu'on n'assiste pas de façon
suffisante sur le plan sanitaire est ce
le plan juridique et puis alors le gros
drame de la séparation des membres d'une
famille d'une même famille problème du
placement qui est vraiment une violence
qui est faite qui est faite aux familles
et puis cette problématique qui est la
discrimination pour origine sociale atd
quart monde veut se battre pour
combattre cette discrimination pour
origine sociale le fait que bon on
exclut les gens parce que disons telle
ou telle origine et ça c'est atd
quart-monde mouvement international
intervient sur tous ces domaines
d'exclusion absolument depuis quand
peut-être précisément atd quart monde et
un mouvement qui a été créée il ya
maintenant plus de 50 ans puisque dès la
fin des années 50
dekra est créé dans un monde sans logis
à noisy-le-grand dans l'est de la région
parisienne sur ces idées là voilà
l'assistance est une bonne chose mais
elle ne suffit pas loin de là il faut
pouvoir faire en sorte que l'ensemble
des personnes qui sont exclues puisse
retrouver l'accès à leurs droits
fondamentaux alors l'accès aux droits
fondamentaux on a incité quelques années
déjà c'est l'habitat c'est surtout
l'éducation et la culture c'est le
travail c'est
c'est le fait de pouvoir vivre en
famille voilà c'est un ensemble de
choses donc qui sont normalement
communément partagée mais dont les
populations les plus exclues lesquels la
solution vous fait des constats avec ce
rapport quels sont les moyens d'action
mis les grands moyens d'action qu'on a
qu'on a préconisé c'est que il faut
absolument faire en sorte que ce silence
soit rompu donc il faut aller gens de
ces populations les plus exclues et puis
incité les pouvoirs publics alors là
vous m'interrogez sur l'action d'un tel
égarement d'une façon générale l'autre
aspect de l'action gk la présence auprès
des populations n'est plus exclue
l'autre aspect c'est d'être très présent
sur le plan politique je dirais sans
options politiques mais ce qu'on veut
c'est éveiller les consciences des
citoyens éveiller les consciences des
hommes politiques sur ces problématiques
l'a donc le la grosse la grosse la
grande solution également
après qu'on ait se soit efforcé chacun
d'eux rompent le silence c'est d'inciter
les pouvoirs publics à aller au devant
de ces personnes les plus exclues et de
rétablir le dialogue est donc pour vous
faire entendre il ya cette journée du
refus de la misère le 17 octobre des
actions seront menées notamment dans le
département des yvelines la journée qui
sera placé cette année sous le thème de
la misère et violence un vous l'avez
bien compris les actions vont débuter
dès le 12 octobre oui elle département d
absolument et débute dès demain par une
grande soirée débat qu'on organise à la
maison de quartier de porchefontaine
versailles donc sur ce thème là comme
vous le lisiez de la violence
la misère et violence on va projeter un
film qui est en effet un extrait des
témoignages ou des contributions plutôt
qu'ils ont pu être apportés par les
personnes les plus exclues pendant ce
colloque c'est un petit film d'une demi
heure qui va permettre ensuite
d'orienter les débats et de
demander la participation de chacun tout
le monde est invité bien évidemment à
participer à ce débat plus grands
dossiers où justement qui vient assister
à ce genre de débat ben forcément le
contexte est un peu difficile tout le
monde sans être dans la misère ressent
des difficultés au quotidien donc se dit
est-ce qu'on va aussi avoir la misère
qu'il ya partout dans le monde où on
espère bien que y aura le plus grand
nombre de personnes la solidarité joue
toujours il n'y a pas de phénomène aussi
de repli sur soi je crois que
malheureusement dans ces périodes de
difficultés économiques pour chacun et
c'est évident qu'on a une certaine
tendance à se replier sur soi bien qu'
il faut le savoir la misère se développe
le nombre de personnes qui sont en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté à l'heure
actuelle s'est accru les chiffres sont
parus au mois de septembre s'est accru
de 5% entre 2009 et 2010 donc
malheureusement - cetc on pouvait s'en
douter et malheureusement à cause de
cette crise économique cette la misère
augmente mais il faut justement
s'efforcer davantage de la combattre
vous avez mentionné la maison de
quartier de porsche fontaine on va voir
quelques images ans et l'exposition
également qui a lieu jusqu'au 20 octobre
quelques mots sur cette exposition qui
accompagne en tout cas la soirée débat
qui sera le 12 octobre d'abord elle a
lieu elle elle a démarré mardi dernier à
mieux jusqu'au 29 jusqu'au 29 octobre
alors effectivement elle se développe
sur plusieurs niveaux dans les maisons
de quartier de porchefontaine on le voit
là et elle traite de deux thèmes
principaux le 17 octobre évidemment
journée mondiale du refus de la misère
j'en ai qui a été instituée d'ailleurs
il ya 25 ans on va fêter le 25e
anniversaire cette année donc ça c'est
un premier élément une première premier
élément l'exposition et le second c'est
la culture de l'exclusion
montre quelques photos témoignages de
familles qui vivent dans l'exclusion
voilà pour cette exposition à découvrir
on continue à regarder ce qui est
proposé dans le département des yvelines
on profite de votre présence 16 et 17 17
c'est la journée nationale mais il ya
donc y aura des rendez vous mais on a
aussi le 16 un mot sur l'arrêt du 16
alors le cese on organise une seconde
soirée débat à la mairie de luz yens sur
un thème un peu différent mais bon tous
rejoint quand même sur sur la misère
telle qu'elle est le combat contre la
misère est ce qu'on peut faire pour
rendre la dignité pour faire en sorte
que les populations les plus exclues
retrouve la dignité c'est un autre type
de débat et laon le on le fera en
engagera ce débat après la diffusion
d'un film 50 ans de combat qui est
effectivement la vie du net et des cas
remontent depuis 50 ans en outre bien ce
qui a été dit clairement elle ce sera à
la mairie de louveciennes donc sur ce
thème soirée débat à 20h30 absolument et
le 17 journées nature lundi cette grande
taille journée mondiale du refus de la
misère alors effectivement paris mais
d'abord dans les yvelines on a quelque
chose à saint germain en laye puisque
vous êtes ce
toute personne qui est à proximité de
saint germain en laye est invité à se
rendre à 14h30 à la salle des arts toit
rue de la république à saint germain où
on va organiser une après midi festive
autour d'un film encore une fois je
témoigne de vous d'un diaporama d'une
réalisation d'un arbre un message et
puis d'un spectacle de marionnettes sur
ce thème de la solidarité et puis ça se
terminera par un goûter et puis le 17
dont l or ledit cette grande journée et
là on a décidé de faire une grande
action à paris puisque elle va se
concrétiser par une marche qui aura lieu
de la pitié salpêtrière
jusqu'au trocadéro le trocadéro est le
lieu traditionnel on se retrouve chaque
17 octobre donc là on va organiser cette
marche qui partira vers 12h45 de la
pitié salpêtrière en passant par
différents endroits dont le palais
bourbon qui était emblématique pour
pouvoir présenter et rencontrer un
certain nombre de députés et le conseil
économique social evry environnementales
ou là on présentera un certain nombre de
propositions conseiller vous pouvez agir
contre la misère avec atd quart monde en
participant à ces différents rendez vous
merci d'être venu nous les présenter la
misère qui progresse vous nous l'avez
dit vous avez commenté les derniers
chiffres merci dominique vienne
responsable yvelinois dates et des
écarts monde culture à présent pour
poursuivre cette édition du 7 8 nous
sommes encore ensemble pendant une demi
heure on va parler d'économie dans un
instant dans un instant mais déjà
culture la ville de bois d'arcy a
dévoilé le programme de la saison de la
grange de la tramblais elle les
rendez-vous ne manquent pas reportage de
johanna soudry au mois d'octobre la vie
culturelle reprend peu à peu il en est
ainsi à bois d'arcy après son ouverture
de saison la grange de la tramblais
accueil yvan le bolloc'h et ma guitare
s'appelle reviens pour un spectacle
entre musique et moelleux ce qui nuit
les
et quand même
en
et d'enchaîner
allez
dans cette salle qui peut accueillir
jusqu'à 370 personnes la programmation
se veut éclectique théâtre chants et
danses et il faut vos responsables de la
programmation nous confie ses coups de
coeur ça va être perco sakineh compagnie
irlandaise qui entre stomp et les
paillettes ombre du groupe ce qu'un
spectacle assez hallucinant de
percussions à la fois il est en bourreau
japonais et des petits yeux pleins de
sable donc c'est un vrai spectacle
drôles étonnants anciens possible que
j'aie une particulière attention aux
siècles d'art moderne et contemporain
compagnie belge qui s'appelle le aoki
fast tech s'appelle mètres carrés qui
paraît être un spectacle assez c'est un
rat comptable c'est inexplicable c'est
une expérience à vivre autour de la
grange la médiathèque de la tramblais
deux structures complémentaires et une
salle qui s'appelle le grenier au
premier étage une très jolie salle sous
les poutres qui est principalement dédié
à toutes les animations jeunesse de la
médiathèque c'est à dire l'heure du
conte une fois par mois un club signer
une fois par mois également une
animation pour les tout petits qui
s'appelle croquelivres qui est fait en
partenariat avec les services de la
petite enfance la boîte à meaux en fait
l'idée c'est de proposer des lectures
spectacles qui donne envie
éventuellement d'aller relire ou d'aller
découvrir des auteurs voilà qu'on n'a
pas forcément
l'habitude d'entendre et puis toujours
dans un esprit de convivialité voilà à
la fin de chaque boîte a beau on discute
on échange autour d'un verre
parmi les têtes d'affiché retrouvée sur
la scène de la grange la tremblay guy
bedos ou charles berling la
programmation complète est disponible
sur internet